foreign
and I also love innovation
however often when I speak about
Innovation within the field of nursing I
met with
uh
and it's understandable
Innovation and Technology within the
healthcare sector is growing really fast
and sometimes it can be a little bit
difficult to keep up with the new
technologies
and now as a new professional within the
field I'm slowly starting to relate a
little bit more to this response
us nurses are already really busy we're
not offered the opportunity to innovate
and quite frankly we're not paid enough
however
if we could change this attitude of
innovation earlier on during nursing
education
I believe we could have our future
nurses innovate in a way to improve the
work and quality for healthcare
professionals which in turn will improve
patient care
this is the key to making our future
nurses the stakeholders within the
future development of the Healthcare
System
so
what is innovation
it's a bit of an ambiguous word that can
mean a lot of different things to many
different people
but simply put it Innovation is looking
at a problem understanding it and trying
to make it better
and if you make it better that's
innovation
Innovation can be applied to something
which already exists or can be used to
develop something completely new
but before we go deeper into this topic
let me tell you all the story which
inspired me to have this speech here
today
when I started my final internship for
my nursing studies at the end of 2020. I
had an interview with award manager on
the first day
one of the questions which she asked me
was
so Ben where do you see yourself going
in the next five to ten years
honestly I have to think about it for a
little while
and then I told her
well to be honest I don't think I can be
a nurse forever it's really hard work
like really really hard both physically
and emotionally but I am passionate
about health care I would love to pursue
future career and Healthcare Innovation
and Technology
and yes
I know assume you might think it's a
little bit strange for near graduate to
be planning on leaving his career on the
first day of his internship
and you know what she said well she said
oh I see I'm not too sure about this
whole Innovation thing I'm not really a
big fan
okay I was taken aback
see that's what I wanted to do
the egotistical part of me wanted to say
what do you mean you don't like
Innovation you don't want to improve the
working quality for healthcare
professionals which in turn will improve
patient care
well I didn't say that obviously
instead I asked her one simple question
and that was
why
and what she told me gave me the biggest
light bulb moment
she said
well too often a business person or
engineer comes to me with a new
technology or Innovative idea and more
often than not it's not very user
friendly or it just adds more to our
workload
okay so I'm standing there and I'm
thinking
ding
this is the moment that I realized
there's there's a huge disconnect
between the developer and the end user
within the healthcare sector
in fact this isn't the first time I've
gotten this kind of response
throughout my studies and now my career
I've often recognized that there's a bit
of a
frustration Factor whenever new
technologies or processes are introduced
so on our days full of taking making
reports taking patients vitals
communicating with doctors
physiotherapists family members taking
patients vitals again and and charting
and God am I forgetting something
well
that's honestly on a good day
but most of the time we're covering for
our colleagues who are away on sick
leave due to burnout
taking on extra administrative roles
because hospitals are trying to save
money
and answering call Pals
the call Bells
especially to Independent patients who
all of a sudden
can't do anything for themselves anymore
so if there's anybody out there who
knows a nurse which most of you probably
do go ahead and ask them to share a
story with you about call bells and
these kinds of patients they're often
quite amusing but at the time oh so
frustrating
so yeah
adding a new technology or process on
top of all of this especially when
they're going through beta stage flaws
only
adds on to the headache
and you see nursing's changing
it's not the same that it was 20 to 30
years ago
neither is the healthcare system and
seems like education is not quite caught
up
a lot of new technologies are being
introduced and most of nurses time still
being spent completing mundane and
repetitive tasks
in addition to this we're seeing an
aging population
we're seeing an increase in the cost of
care patients needs are more demanding
and a shortage in healthcare staff
however
we could have these repetitive and
mundane tasks of charting aided by Ai
and technology is as small as a ring
taking patients vitals
this would hopefully leave more time for
nurses to communicate and provide care
for their patients
but also give them an opportunity to
solve problems within their
organizations
in fact the World Health Organization
estimates that by 2030 there's going to
be a global Health Care shortage with 9
million of those being nursing specific
this is caused by experienced nurses
coming towards the retirement
poor retention rate of new professionals
and less people entering the field
altogether
it's not looking very good
so we're at a point now where we can no
longer wait and see if these
advancements will happen in the
healthcare sector
we're at a point now where these
advancements technologies have to happen
but who are the ones who should be
driving these advancements and
Technologies
well the answer is Frontline healthcare
workers nurses
we're the ones who have been using all
of the Technologies which have been
introduced thus far we work with them
every day see where their flaws are and
some of us might have pretty good ideas
on how to make them better
but most importantly us nurses are the
ones who truly understand what aspects
of our jobs can be replaced with future
Technologies
if we can combine
the front line experience of nurses with
the Innovative approaches of business
people and Engineers just imagine the
improvements we could see
foreign
we could actually start solving the
problems nurses face every day by
including them
the end user within the development
phase
so that comes now to my main question
how do we solve this multi-dimensional
issue it is quite a big one
well a good start would be by looking
into our education system
from my experience going through my
bachelor degree in nursing they take a
bunch of nursing students where a nurse
in the front of the class teaches them
about nursing and it makes sense
but what this does is it creates a
nursing bubble within the university and
sometimes it can be a little bit
difficult to penetrate through that
barrier
what it does is it Narrows your path to
where what you learn is only useful for
that profession without exploration of
problem solving within the industry
as a nursing student going through a
bachelor degree you're merely handed the
tools and taught how to use them there's
very little emphasis on being able to
look at that tool and thinking aha
this would work much better if it was
made like this
and here's the thing
universities are networking Havens
we're literally working in
establishments where we have people
working on business and marketing I.T
engineering design culture Healthcare
and that is only the tip of the iceberg
as a student
I was lucky enough to be a part of a
group who were really keen on
extracurricular Innovation projects
we had a diverse group of students
myself a nurse two industrial designers
a cultural manager and a health Tech
engineer
this experience taught me so much about
the importance of networking and how to
work within a multi-professional team
and I couldn't help but think that every
single student should have an
opportunity like this and solve real
life problems
but most importantly it showed me that
we needed each other
to make this project become alive
during the same time we also established
a non-profit which looked at enriching
the Innovative and entrepreneurial
culture amongst the University students
I
was lucky to have an experience like
this
and I should acknowledge that there are
the beginnings of innovation education
within nursing studies
but it's at its infancy stage and not
held as a priority within the classroom
so
if there's any
nursing Educators out there
in fact
all educators
who aren't already doing this is to if
there's one thing I would like to ask is
that you let your students out of that
bubble
make them
professionally mix and match internet
act Network and work on projects with
students going through different courses
within your University
from my experience in the projects that
I did with my colleagues I can see a
huge benefit in this kind of
cross-course collaboration
what might come out of it can be truly
special and the connections you get from
them would can last a lifetime
now when you really think about it
how can we develop
easily adoptable Technologies for nurses
if we never get a chance to learn how to
really sit down and work within a
multi-professional team
so in our future careers as Healthcare
professionals when we come across a
potential problem we can draw from those
past experiences and networks we gain to
students to at least get started with
Innovation process
now there are many barriers nurses and
health Tech developers face within the
healthcare sector
educating our nurses about Innovation
and what's to come in the future of the
Healthcare System we can slowly start to
make them the stakeholders within the
strategy
however education is not an end-all
solution
the solution lies in a more integrative
approach where education technology
governance leadership laws finances are
all taken into consideration but these
are all entire tedx talks in themselves
and outside of my personal experience
so if there's anybody out there
listening who's an expert within the
field I would like to invite somebody to
come up here and speak about how we can
start solving these issues we need to
get this ball rolling because time is
seriously starting to run out
and now for myself as a new professional
within the field if there's a message
that I would like to share that is that
if you're a startup innovator business
person engineer or anybody working on a
healthcare related technology or service
getting caught with the nurse ask us how
can this product or service be made
better to suit our needs better
trust me we want to help that's
kind of why we're nurses to begin with
and while I'm on the topic I would also
like to encourage nurses and students to
get more involved
find like-minded people in societies
these might be part of the hospital
you're working for within your local
University
and if you have a business or innovation
idea share it speak to people and find
other services within your community
there are healthcare related hackathons
incubators and other kinds of services
to help you construct these ideas better
now Studies have shown that Innovation
empowers nurses
when it looks at ways of improving
patient care Technologies and processes
however
this is only possible with financial
support
Healthcare leaders promoting an
environment where intellectual
creativity is promoted
and employees get the recognition and
Prestige that they deserve
however
time and time again
when I've spoken to nurses as a student
and now as a professional it seems like
there's something preventing nurses from
achieving this
there's something fundamentally
preventing nurses from innovating more
well
nurses are overworked
burning out underpaid
often unappreciated with their own
organizations especially within the
public sector
but most importantly
we aren't offered the opportunity to
truly demonstrate our potential
now
as Ai and Technologies assume many tasks
of nurses in the near future we need to
educate and facilitate our future nurses
to be the stakeholders within the future
development of the Healthcare System
our future nurses will be the health
care information integrators Healthcare
Consultants health coaches and providers
of human care
supported by these Technologies and AI
not replaced by them
after all
one of the first human interactions you
have in life is with a nurse in the
maternity ward
and one of your last
will be with a nurse by your bedside
the way we support our nurses in society
is a choice
so please help us nurses
so we can help you innovate
let's build a better future together
thank you
[Applause]